mass effect one and one and two is
a game are games that i really really
love they were so
immersive being part of the spaceship
going far out in the galaxy
where where did it go wrong
so
[Music]
the new mass effect andromeda is coming
out
and it's uh it's looking pretty
interesting
what happened what happened where did it
go wrong
these are the template phases for any
female characters we have
what the [ __ ] and what the [ __ ]
we also have what the [ __ ] and what the
[ __ ]
and what the [ __ ] and what the [ __ ]
what okay listen i get it
they look like normal people but take
final fantasy just an example
look at just compare their facial
expression all right she's making she's
even making a face
it looks it looks attractive it looks
interesting
what the actual [ __ ] would you call this
then 2017 the peak
of video gaming how much is how much
does this game
cost 40 million
40 million dollars 40 million
where did those 40 million dollars go i
don't
it gets better it gets better so the the
main character
in this uh in this one her face is um
what should we call it a special it's uh
she makes uh she makes interesting you
know she's an interesting character
it really feels like a human character
that i can relate to fine
finally thank you bioware now this this
is what i always wanted in gaming
jesus oh my god
but bioware i want to know i i want to
know what happened
2008 2017
now those are just the facial
expressions let's take a look
at some of the pixar worthy animations
this face
what are you what is happening there
she must be constipated maybe maybe they
haven't solved that in
in in the future in space constipation
has
always and will always be a problem for
humanity
it's ironic because the faces she makes
is the same faces i make
when i see these animations
this one i love
what is happening
oh hell yeah it's terrifying it's
[ __ ] terrifying
i used to love mass effect it was the
best one of my favorite games
ever it was so good
i have like 200 hours in those games
what is that face bioware why does she
look
at her eyes
i think she just realized that she's a
shitty animation what is he doing
he's beginning to believe
it's too beautiful this is too beautiful
it makes me happy
i can't honestly this makes me i wasn't
honestly i wasn't sure if i was going to
buy the game but now 100
i am going to play the game look at that
flawless movement it feels like i'm
there
and the action so intense so
really it almost feels like i'm throwing
the punch myself
look at this danny yes
this isn't hollywood you don't have to
fake punches you can actually punish
them
by the way i don't know i don't know if
you're aware of this but uh
you can't actually punch because they're
not real they're not real so you can
punch them i i think it's okay no one's
gonna be offended
at least you know i can't speak for
everyone but i i think at least i think
at least
uh the flawless the flawless walking
animations this is how
humans walk this is how we should be
walking
if you are walking other ways you're
walking wrong
best game the reviews aren't out for
this game yet but i can imagine it's
going to be a meta score of
99 on metacritic taking over zelda
that lip movement this is how
you talk don't you know i imagine that
they were inspired by zelda cgi when
they made this
sell that zdi which of course has some
of the finest animation of all time
they modeled a gun
backwards is this real
i can't tell they they model a gun
backwards
i'm sorry but how is that possible
i i can't get
can you imagine it can you imagine if
someone shows up to you and be like hey
give me your [ __ ] money you know some
people have been criticizing
mass effect andromeda for uh selling out
essentially you know
just living off the title and not making
a great game
disgusting it's disgusting to even make
these claims
because that that has never been done
before
ever in gaming alright call of duty gets
better
every single year dragon age one of my
favorite games got better
by every title
sonic is like the finest whiskey
the more it ages the better that it gets
actually that's that's true
[Music]
halo first one was garbage
the the latest one was so good so much
better
than the other ones bungie didn't know
what they were doing with halo
definitely not
[Music]
and the love scenes
always so beautiful they speak to my
very soul
i wish i didn't have a girlfriend so i
can watch these
i i with full intent yes
yes
what is that face that's how you show
emotion
this is why video games needs to be
nominated as oscars because there's so
much
art and expression and drama in
in every single frame 40 million huh
can't wait to play it finally a
character i can relate to
finally a game with animation so good
[Music]
it makes you feel like you're there
finally a studio that shows the passion
in video game
you should have you should you should
have killed the game just kill it which
you should have killed it with shepard
god damn i missed commander shepard
let it just be clear uh the game might
still be great
you know these are these are just flaws
based on you know restricted footage so
i'm sure
like over the 100 hours of gameplay
there's not going to be any more
floss uh ex litalis made a comparison of
the two 10 years was it 10 years mass
effect came out
look at this
look at the facial inspection and the
difference
oh my god bruh look at this dude
wait till you see the oh no
look at the top of his head
[Laughter]
look at his lips
this is why i don't play games anymore
thank you bioware god bless you physical
integrity
sarah is my brother okay
scott's fine his vitals are strong but
the revival procedure was interrupted
when can he wake up we don't want to
rush it
sam my connection to scott's implant was
suspended
however his pulse respiration and brain
activity are all normal